although aws kind of does a shitty job
of like i'm continually surprised like
mechanical turk for example how shitty
the interface is
we're talking about like rev making me
feel good
like when i first discovered mechanical
turk
the initial idea of it was like it made
me feel like ref does but then the
interface is like
come on yeah it's horrible why
why is that so painful does nobody at
amazon
want to like seriously invest in it felt
like you could make
so much money if you took this effort
seriously
and it feels like they have a committee
of like two people just sitting back
like like a meeting they meet once a
month like what are we gonna do with
mechanical turk
if it's like uh two websites making me
feel like this that and
craiglist.org whatever the hell it is
yeah it feels like it's designed in the
90s well craigslist
basically hasn't been updated pretty
much since the game do you seriously
think there's a team
like how big is the team working on a
mechanical turk i don't know their thumb
team right
i feel like tourism i'm skeptical yeah
well if it's not possible they benefit
from you know the other teams
like moving things forward right in a
small way
possible but no i know you mean we do we
use mechanical turf for a couple of
things as well and
yeah it's painfully painful but yeah it
works actually i think most people the
thing is most people don't really use
the ui right
like so right like we for example that's
right use it through the api
right so yeah but even the api
documentation and so on
like it's super outdated like yeah it's
it i don't i don't even know what to
i mean the same like same criticism as
long as we're ranting
my same criticism goes to the apis of
most of these companies like google for
example the api for
the different services it's just the
documentation
is so shitty like it's not
so shady i should i should actually be
uh
i should exhibit some gratitude
okay let's practice some graphics
gratitude the
the you know the documentation is pretty
good like
most of the things that the api makes
available is pretty good
it's just that in the sense that it's
accurate
sometimes outdated but like the degree
of explanations with examples
is only covering i would say like 50
of what's possible and it just feels a
little bit like there's a lot of
natural questions that people would want
to ask that doesn't uh
doesn't get covered and it feels like
it's almost there
like it's such a magical thing like the
maps api
youtube api there's a bunch i gotta
imagine it's like you know
there's probably some team at google
right responsible for writing this
documentation it's probably not
the engineers right and exactly this
team is not
you know where you want to be well it's
a it's a weird thing i i sometimes think
about this
for somebody who wants to also uh build
the company
i think about this a lot
you know youtube the you know the
service
is one of the most magical like i'm so
grateful that youtube exists
and yet they seem to be quite clueless
on so many things like that everybody is
screaming them
at like it feels like whatever the
mechanism
that you use to listen to your
quote-unquote customers which is like
the creators
is not very good like there's literally
people that are like screaming why
like uh their new youtube studio for
example there's like features
that that were like begged for for a
really
long time like being able to upload
multiple videos at the same time
that was missing for a really really
long time
now like there's probably things that i
don't know which is
maybe for that kind of huge
infrastructure it's actually very
difficult to build some of these
features
but the fact that that wasn't
communicated and it felt like
you're not being heard like i remember
this experience for me and it's not a
pleasant experience and it feels like
the company doesn't give a damn about
you
and that's something to think about i'm
not sure what that is
that might have to do with just like
small groups working on these small
features
and these specific features and there's
no overarching like
dictator type of human that says like
why the hell are we neglecting like
steve jobs type of character is like
there's people that we need to we need
to speak to the people that
like want to love our product and they
don't let's maybe at some point you just
get so fixated on the numbers right and
it's like well the numbers are pretty
great right
like people are watching you know it
doesn't seem to be a problem right
and you're not like the person that like
built this thing right so you really
care about it
yeah you know you're just there you came
in as a product manager right you got
hired sometime later
your mandate is like increase this the
number like you know
10 right and you just that's brilliantly
put like if you
this is the okay if there's a lesson in
this is
don't reduce your company into a metric
of like
how much uh like you said how much how
much people watching the videos and so
on
and and and like convince yourself that
everything is working just because the
numbers are going up
yeah there's something you have to have
a vision
you have to uh you have to want people
to love
your stuff because love is ultimately
the beginning of like
a successful long-term company is they
always should love
your product you have to be like a
creator and have that like creator's
love for your own thing right like
and you paint by you know these these
comments right
and probably like now apple i think did
this generally like
really well you know they're well known
for kind of keeping teams small
even when they were big right and you
know you as an engineer like there's
that book uh creative selection i don't
know if you read it by a
apple engineer named ken cocienda it's
kind of a great book actually because
unlike most of these business books
where it's you know
here's how steve job ran the company
it's more like here's how life was like
for me you know an engineer here the
projects i worked on and hear what it
was like to pitch steve jobs you know
on like you know i think it was
uncharted like the keyboard and the
audit correction right
um and at apple like steve jobs reviewed
everything and so he was like
this is what it was like to show my
demos to steve jobs and you know
to change them because like steve jobs
didn't like how you know the shape of
the little key
was off because the rounding of the
corner was like not quite right or
something like this but it was
famously a stickler for this kind of
stuff but because the teams were small
you really owned the stuff right so you
really cared
yeah elon musk does that similar kind of
thing with tesla which is
really interesting there's another
lesson in leadership in that
is to be obsessed with the details and
like he talks to like the lowest level
engineers
you